J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So as you
know, we're getting on to ionic
reactions, and started by
talking about how important
the solvent is.
We started last time looking at
the example of the
disassociation of water into
ions to give H+ and O-H-,
both, of course, solvated.
We're interested in the
important role that the
solvent plays.
We saw last time that we could
talk about
water in the gas phase.
Dissociating into radicals, we
know the bond
dissociation energy.
Then transferring an electron.
And most importantly, then
getting the two ions apart
from one another, which is going
to cost 332 kilocalories
per mole just to get them apart
from being like one
Å to infinitely apart.
Altogether those processes cost
kilocalories per mole.
So that would be absolutely out
of the question.
In fact, even once you start in
the gas phase it's 386, so
that would be 10^-290.
Impossible.
But the solvent makes it
possible-- you know that water
dissociates.
So when you put another water
molecule, which is a dipole,
next to the O-H-, it makes it
more stable.
We talked about that last time
or two times ago how you get
hydrogen bonding between a
hydroxide anion and a water.
So it's more, in that case, more
than just a dipole.
Remember it was that double
minimum that, in fact, the
lowest energy level had the
hydrogen in the middle.
Anyhow, that's not fabulously
strong; it's not like a
covalent bond, but it's 28
kilocalories per mole, which
is nothing to sneeze at.
If you put another water on that
you get another 18
kilocalories per mole.
And if you put another and
another and another and
another and they line up, you
get stability by 106
kilocalories per mole for
solvating the hydroxide ion,
to put it in water.
So that's worth more than most
covalent bonds.
Now you also have the proton
that could be solvated.
That one actually forms a bond--
you can form a bond between the
unshared pair on the water
that's coming up and the H+.
That bond is, in fact, a very
strong bond.
It's 164 kilocalories per mole--
about twice as strong
as most covalent bond.
Because it's not only a bond, it
also gets the positive
charge in close proximity to a
bunch of other electrons.
So it polarizes them.
That's a little bit like
solvation within the molecule.
So you get 164 just for the
first water onto a proton.
Then, of course, that looks
rather-- it's charged and it's
not very much bigger than the
O-H-.
So it's not going to surprise
you that you can put more
waters onto that.
And from doing a whole bunch of
waters to put it into
liquid water, you get another
100 kilocalories per mole on
top of what you got forming
H3O+.
So if we sum all those together,
164, 106 and 100--
notice that those are similar to
one another--
we get 370 kilocalories per
mole.
That means we get the energy of
forming the proton and the
hydroxide if they're solvated
down to within only 21 and a
half kilocalories of the water
in water.
So that means the pKa is 15.8,
you know.
But it has enormously to do with
solvation,
as you can see here.
It's, in fact, very delicately
balanced.
It's a small difference, this 22
kilocalories per mole, of
very large numbers, things that
total 392
kilocalories per mole.
So if any of these steps had
been off by a few percent, the
dissociation of water would be
very different.
So this is a sign that you have
to be careful, because
whenever you're dealing with
small differences that come
from very large effects in the
first place, it
could go any place.
In the case of water it happens
to be that water will
dissociate with a dissociation
constant of [correction:
10^16] 16.
But it has to be regarded mostly
as an accident because
of this important role of
solvation.
Now we're going to generalize
into Brønsted acidity--
other things giving up protons.
Or you could call it
substitution at hydrogen.
Here's HF--
and we talked about this last
semester ad infinitum, of how
we could make and break a bond
at the same time by bringing
up, say, water, and get H3O+ and
F-.
That is, HF acting as an acid,
hydrofluoric acid.
So that's Brønsted acidity,
giving up a proton, but it could
be thought of as
substitution at hydrogen--
something new comes in, the old
thing leaves,
fluoride in this case.
Now this happens, of course, in
a solvent.
Just as in the case of water, HF
isn't going to disassociate
to H+ and F- in the gas phase.
It's the stabilization of those
ions by water that make
this accessible.
So is it going to be like water
where you have these
enormous things and there's no
predicting what will happen,
as to how strong the acid will
be?
To a certain extent that's true.
But fortunately, the solvation
energies of analogous
compounds are similar enough
that we can often make
reasonably accurate
predictions--
or at least if not predict, at
least once we've seen the
results we could rationalize
them reasonably--
of the relative acidities in
terms of molecular structures.
That is, if we can cancel out,
because they're very similar,
all these solvation things, then
we can look at the
molecules themselves and try to
understand why one is more
acidic than another.
That's what we'd like to be able
to do because it's much
simpler to think about just the
molecule than to think
about how all the solvents would
be arranged around any
particular molecule or ion.
So let's try that.
Now as background for talking
about acid you've, in your AP
chemistry, looked at pH and pKa,
and there's the question
why should organic chemists
bother about pH and pKa, which
you've already done in your AP.
It seems like a topic for
general
chemistry, not organic
chemistry.
But there are several reasons
why it's important in organic
chemistry, and I'm sure that all
those various textbooks
you have have a chapter, a
section,
about Brønsted acidity.
Because in the first place,
whether a molecule is ionized
or not is important for
predicting reactivity--
that is, the availability of
HOMOs and LUMOs--
how high, how low they'll be
depends on
whether it's an ion.
Also things like conformation,
the color, the proximity to
other species, mobility,
particularly if you're an
electric field, is a big
function of
whether there's a charge.
So you want to know whether
molecules are ionized or not.
One of the simplest ways of
making ions is
dissociating a proton.
And because the ease with which
a species reacts with a
proton might predict how readily
it
reacts with other LUMOs.
So often we're not specifically
interested in how
easily a proton would react with
some high HOMO, but we
are interested in how someone
else would react.
And if we're comparing two high
HOMOs to see which one's
more reactive, it wouldn't be
surprising if the one that's
more reactive with a proton is
also more reactive with the
molecule we're interested in.
So if we can easily measure
reactivity with a proton, the
reverse of which is acidity, if
we can easily measure that
equilibrium, then we have a
scale to talk about how low
LUMOs are, how reactive LUMOs
might be.
So that's why acidity is
particularly important in
organic chemistry, because it
could
predict organic reactions.
That is, reaction with the LUMO
sigma* CX or pi*
CO might parallel the reactivity
with a proton.
Now we know that the acid
dissociation constant is the
product of [H+] and [B-] over
[HB] where B is some base
or HB an acid.
And if we take the logs of both
sides and rearrange a
little bit, we see that the pH
is the pKa minus the log of
the ratio--
how much of the stuff is ionized
and how much of the
stuff is in the acidic form.
If that ratio is 1, if it's half
ionized, then the log of
1 is zero so we forget that.
And then pH is equal to pKa.
So we have an acid with a
certain pKa.
If the pH is that value, then
you have 50:50 ionized and
unionized form.
Now you often use things like
that as indicators.
It might be that the ionic form
is colored or has a
different color from the
protonated form.
Then if you see that color or
not and can measure its
intensity, you can tell how much
is ionized.
So you could measure that ratio.
But you can't measure it over a
really wide range, because
suppose you could measure it
when there's 5% of the colored
species or up to 95%, but beyond
that the colors aren't
distinguishable.
That would be fairly reasonable.
So if you go from 95:5 to 5:95
that covers just this ratio,
that covers just 2 and a half pH
units.
So if you want to use an
indicator to measure the pH of
something, you can only measure
it with that indicator
over a very narrow range by
measuring the ratio of how
much colored to uncolored stuff
there is.
Beyond that you have to get some
other indicator and then
some other indicator and some
other indicator.
So you could have a ladder of
indicators that allows you to
cover a wide range of pH.
And then you could bootstrap
that way with overlapping
indicators to get a wide
coverage.
So with a known pKa, you measure
the pH by measuring
the ratio of the ions-- ionized
to the unionized form.
Now let's look at factors that
influence the acidity, because
they may also be the ones that
influence reactivity and other
organic reactions.
Now pKa normally is defined in
water.
We just saw that the
dissociation constant for
water in water, that is, losing
the red
proton there, is 15.7.
Now if you tried to get the pH
higher than
that, what would happen?
If you had water and you made
its pH 20, let's say, or 18
instead of some place in this
range, what would happen?
You'd have the strong base in
there.
That base would pull protons off
the water, and you
wouldn't have any water anymore.
So it wouldn't be anything like
the same solvent if you
tried to get higher pH than
that.
And the same thing is true if
you look at the dissociation
constant of H3O+.
At a pH of -1.7 it would be 50%
protonated.
But if water is 50% protonated
it's not water anymore.
So if you're within this range
between, say, zero and 15 or
something like that, then you
have water and you can talk
about things.
But if you tried to get out of
that, you can't use water
anymore because all you're doing
is making all
the water into ions.
But in that range you can work.
So in that range there are a
number of interesting things,
like ammonia can be protonated.
The ammonium ion has a pKa of
9.2.
So at pH 9.2 half of ammonia is
protonated, the ammonium
ion, half of it is NH3.
Does it surprise you--
now let's get this straight.
So NH4 acting as an acid, in
NH4+ is 9.2.
H3O+ is -1.7.
Which one gives up its proton
more easily?
H3O+ or NH4+?
Which is a stronger acid?
Which one would take the proton
from the other one?
Debbie, do you have an idea?
STUDENT: I guess H3O+ is a
stronger acid.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it would protonate NH3.
So if you had H3O+ and NH3, it
would be downhill in energy to
transfer the proton to the NH3.
Why?
Why is it better to put the
proton onto NH3 than onto H2O?
What is it about NH3?
That makes that a stronger bond.
So you have a proton plus
something that has an unshared
pair, they come together in the
form of a bond.
How much energy are you going to
get out of that bond?
The proton is the same in all
cases.
What difference is there in the
unshared pair between
nitrogen and oxygen that means
that nitrogen will hold the
proton more strongly.
Sebastian?
STUDENT: It's a higher HOMO
because nitrogen has a lower
nuclear charge.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Lower nuclear charge, higher
HOMO, stronger bond.
Better energy match.
So we understand that difference
here
of about 11 pH units.
Here's FH, 3.2, hydrofluoric
acid.
Not nearly as good an acid as
H3O+.
But it's a lot better acid than
H-O-H, than water, by 12
and a half powers of 10.
The reason is the same.
That oxygen has a higher HOMO
and holds
the proton more strongly.
So we can understand that.
H2S is 7.0.
‘So now that seems a little
funny compared with water.
But notice the bond association
energies.
Actually, it's reasonable--
sulfur is not as electronegative
as oxygen.
Its HOMO is lower.
Pardon me, let me get this
straight.
You always have to think these
things through.
I realize I'm rattling it off
quite fast, and it'll take a
little while looking this over
in your own room to get it
straight in your head.
But it's interesting that if you
look at the bond
dissociation energies, sulfur is
between oxygen and fluorine.
So it's more than just how
strong the bond is that
determined sulfur to be in the
middle.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about that.
So here are hydrogen attached to
various elements, and we're
going to look at the pKa's.
Now if we go across the top row
you see that the ease of
heterolysis, how strong an acid
it is,
increases to the right.
So it gets easier to break the
bond into ions as
you go to the right.
But if you look at the bond
strength, the bonds get
stronger as you go to the right.
So that ease of homolysis goes
the other way.
But this is exactly what we
talked about a time or two ago
when we looked at the energies
of two things and said that
homolysis and heterolysis are
opposite one another, whether
you take the two electrons or
whether you put them both here
in heterolysis, or whether you
put one here and one up there
in homolysis.
So that's the same thing we
talked about before.
So the energy mismatch, the
electronegativity difference
makes it easier to do
heterolysis, but
harder to do homolysis.
But notice it's not the same
when you go down
the periodic table.
Now the red and the black arrows
are in
the opposite direction.
Fluoride is the most
electronegative, but it's the
weakest acid among the hydrogen
halides.
And in that case, it is the bond
strength that's making
the difference.
And that's what made the sulfur
more acidic than oxygen
is because of the weaker bond
strength.
So that has to do with decrease
of overlap; going
across had to do with the energy
match.
So we understand those things.
Now we can learn, by knowing pKa
values, some of the things
that influence the energies of
these bonds.
So here's an O-H bond in acetic
acid.
Of course, it's called acetic
acid--
water is not called aqueic acid
or something like that.
So this is much more acidic--
4.8 versus 15.7.
So it's 11 powers of 10 stronger
as an acid.
Why?
Is it because the bond is
intrinsically stronger?
They're both O-H sigma bonds.
The bonds are essentially the
same.
But the anions are different--
and we've talked about this
before.
What is it that makes the anion
that you're going to
make here unusually stable
compared to H-O?
STUDENT: Resonance.
PROFESSOR: Right, there's going
to be resonance that'll
make it stable.
Or HOMO-LUMO mixing, if we
wanted not to use the language
of resonance.
So the low LUMO of pi*
stabilizes the electrons we're
putting on oxygen.
Now if you make chloroacetic
acid, then it's another 2
powers of 10 stronger.
Why would that be sensible?
Anybody got an idea about that?
Ellen?
STUDENT: Electron induction by
the chlorine.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's an inductive effect.
The chlorine is electronegative,
it withdraws
electrons from this carbon,
which withdraws electrons from
that carbon, which withdraws
electrons from that oxygen,
and makes that a better place to
put a negative charge.
So it's worth the factor of 100.
So we have some measure here.
Because these equilibrium
constants are easy to measure
for reversible acid
dissociation, it gives us a
scale that's easily accessible
of how important something
like inductive effect can be.
Or if we look at this one where
we're
breaking a C-H bond.
Now normal carbon-hydrogen bonds
aren't acidic, but this
one is rather acidic.
It's as acidic as the ammonium
ion.
Why?
Because there are two pi* vacant
orbitals next door that
can stabilize the high HOMO when
you make carbon minus by
losing that one.
So again, we have a quantitative
measure of how
important this might be.
Now here's an amino acid,
alanine, in the form that's
protonated here on nitrogen, and
its pKa, it's even a
little bit stronger acid than
the chloroacetic acid.
Why would you say so?
Nitrogen is not more
electronegative than chlorine--
not withdrawing more electrons
than chlorine is.
Or is it?
Lauren?
STUDENT: It's got the positive
charge.
PROFESSOR: Ah, the positive
That makes it very
electronegative.
Let's look at that one in a
little more detail.
And it also shows how you
determine these pKa's.
So you can titrate alanine.
You start with this protonated
form in acidic medium at pH 0,
say, and it's got that red
proton that could be lost. And
then we're going to start
running in hydroxide until
we've put in two equivalents of
hydroxide.
When we add the first
equivalent, we'll take off
that red proton.
And then we'll take the one off
the nitrogen when we add a
second equivalent.
But let's look at how the pH
changes as we add the base and
pull off protons.
So it looks like this.
It changes very slowly in there
and
is said to be buffered.
And then it changes rapidly
again.
Now why is that?
Why isn't it just a straight
line as you add more and more
hydroxide and watch the pH
change?
If you want to change the ratio
by 9-fold, you could
change it from 3:1 to 1:3.
So that's a 9-fold change in the
ratio.
And remember, the ratio is
measuring the change in pH.
So if you change the ratio by 9,
say, approximately 10, the
log of 10 is 1, so it would
change the pH of
the solution by 1.
So adding half an equivalent of
base, going from here to
here, changes it by about 1 pKa
unit, 2 to 3.
Now suppose we want to change
the pH from 3 to 4, how much
do we have to add?
If we change the ratio by a
factor of 9-- again, I use 9
just because it's convenient, 3
to 1 to 1 to 3.
If we want to change it by a
factor of 9 again and go up by
another pKa unit, pH unit,
logarithmic unit, then we only
have to go from 1 to 3 to 3 to
100.
That's another factor of 9
change.
But it only takes 0.22
equivalents to do that.
Then if we want to change it by
another log unit, it takes
only 0.03 equivalents.
So during this region when the
ratio is some place close to
50:50, it takes a lot of
conversion in order to change
the ratio very much.
But when you're out at the end
and you only have 1% or a
couple percent of something,
then it doesn't take much
change to change the ratio
enormously.
So that's why you get this
behavior as a buffer, where if
you put a lot of that stuff in,
and you have roughly 50:50 of
the ionized and unionized form,
you can do a lot of
adding acid or base and it
doesn't change the pH
significantly.
But if you're out in this region
where you only have a
few percent of one or the other,
then it changes
drastically.
Now if we keep going, we take
off this proton, and again
it's slow and buffered and then
it goes up again.
Now, how can you find the pKa of
the compound, having done
one of these titrations where
you run in and measure the pH
as you're going along?
Remember, the pKa is the same as
the pH when what?
When the ratio is 50:50.
So that means if we take it
where the ratio is 50:50,
that's the first pKa, the pKa
for this
proton, the red one here.
So the pK1 is 2.35.
Now it's reasonable that the
proximity of the positive
charge to the carboxyl group
that's going to be losing a
proton, having the plus charge
here-- what Lauren
was telling us about--
is going to make it, here it is,
300 times easier to remove
the H+ from this cation rather
than acetic acid, which was
4.5 in its pKa.
So we went from 4.5 to about
2.5.
Well, a little bit more than
We went 300 times better because
of that positive
charge, stabilizing the anion
we're going to get here by
having these two charges near
one another.
So that's reasonable.
Now we take off the second
proton, and we find that
that's pKa 9.87.
Now how would you expect that to
compare with taking a
proton away from a normal amine?
Here we're taking the proton
away from an ammonium ion to
generate an amine, but now we
have a negative charge that's
making this more stable, be
harder to pull away.
So at first glance you'd say it
would be at about the same.
If this was easier by a factor
of 300 because this is so
stable, then this one, taking
that second proton off, should
be harder than 300 compared to a
normal amine because this
thing is so stable.
So with a proximity to the
negative charge should make it
about 300 times harder to remove
proton from this
so-called zwitterion--
the thing that has both positive
and negative charge--
than from a normal amine, like
say ethylamine.
Now ethylamine is pKa 10.6.
It's actually 5 times easier to
take the
proton away from alanine.
From the zwitterion of alanine
it's easier to take it away.
The same way this one was easier
as compared to a normal
ammonium ion.
That seems absolutely backwards-
that it should be 300 times
easier.
Why?
Why is it easier rather than
harder to take it away from
here rather than here?
So you'll notice that it's a
question of compared to what.
Is this a good model for this
when it has a proton on it and
isn't charged?
Not really, because this has
this carbon with a bunch of
oxygens in it.
And this one, the ethylamine
doesn't.
So maybe the electron
withdrawing effect of those
oxygens is making it easier to
give up a proton here,
stabilizing the anion.
The same way chlorine did.
Remember, in chloroacetic acid,
it was withdrawing
electrons and making it easier.
So maybe we should compare this,
not with ethylamine, but
with something that has the
oxygens but
doesn't have the charge.
So we can do that by making it
an ester instead of an acid so
it doesn't have the charge on
it.
Its pKa is 7.3.
So now, in fact, it is harder to
take it away, and it's
about 400 times, about what we
expected if we have the right
comparison.
So having these charges changes
the pKa in a
reasonable way.
So apparently the CO2 group,
lacking charge, is
sufficiently electron
withdrawing to destabilize
that cation more than the
negative charge stabilizes it.
Now notice here we've changed
the scale-- now we're going
from 10 to 50.
We're going to very, very weak
acids.
And, of course, we can't do that
in water because water
has a pKa of 16, and if we try
to get more basic than that we
just convert water into
hydroxide--
it's not water anymore.
So we're going to have to use
other solvents to do that.
But if we use these other
solvents, and again, use
indicators with boot straps to
go on up. Then we get that a
hydrogen attached to nitrogen.
Now we're not talking about an
ammonium ion.
That's what we were just talking
about, taking a proton
away from RNH3+.
It's not that anymore.
it's taking the hydrogen right
away from
nitrogen without the charge.
So it's much harder to take it
away than it is to take it
away from water, which is what
you expect because the energy
match was better here.
And if we go to carbon then it's
way, way up there, 52.
Now in your various books you'll
have
different values of that.
It might vary by as much as 3 or
even 4 pKa units, because
you have to go from one solvent
to another here and
use these indicators to know
what the
equivalent of pH would be.
And it depends on which ones you
use to do that.
But anyhow, it's way up there.
So these values are approximate
because the
equilibrium for bases stronger
than hydroxide can't be
measured in water-- you have to
bootstrap by comparing
these acid base pairs in other
solvents.
So that one's a bad E match for
O-H, a better E match for
N-H, and a great E match for
C-H, so it's holding the bonds
stronger together and making it
harder to form the anions.
Now here's another C-H bond, but
it's
significantly more acidic.
The hydrogen attached to a
double bonded carbon.
Anybody got any ideas why that
would be easier to break?
Can anybody think of an idea why
it might be harder to
break a proton away, to break a
bond to hydrogen when it's
attached to a double-bonded
carbon?
Ellen?
STUDENT: sp2?
PROFESSOR: Ah, it's sp2
hybridized, so the bond's
going to be stronger that you're
going to be breaking.
But, in fact, it's easier to
ionize it.
So it's not because of the bond
strength--
that would go the other
direction.
It must be the ion that's
unusually stable.
Can anybody think about why the
ion might be stable in
this double-bonded carbon, the
unshared pair?
Anurag?
STUDENT: The pi* of the ion will
stabilize the charge.
PROFESSOR: Ah, you could get
resonance.
The pi* stabilizes it, but
thanks for biting on that,
because it doesn't work.
Do you see why?
So here's the two hydrogens on
the carbon, double bond here
on that carbon.
Why is it that when you pull
this proton off and generate a
pair of electrons here, why
isn't it
stabilized by the pi*?
STUDENT: They're orthogonal.
PROFESSOR: They're orthogonal.
So you're not going to get it
that way.
But this orbital is sp2, not
sp3, as it is in the other
one, the one that's 52.
So it's a lower energy orbital
for the electrons to be in, so
it's a more stable anion.
That's good.
Now here's an acetylene that
loses its proton, and it's 20
powers of 10 better at losing
the proton.
Why?
Anurag, let's come back to you
on that one.
STUDENT: The resonance on the
ion?
PROFESSOR: No, it's still not
resonance because--
so here's the carbon, here's the
hydrogen
coming out at you.
There's a pi ‘orbital that's
this way, and a pi orbital
that's this way in the
acetylene, but both of them
are orthogonal to that.
What's good about it?
STUDENT: It sp hybridized.
PROFESSOR: It's sp hybridized.
So here we go from sp3 to sp2 to
sp, and it
gets more and more--
so sp3 anion, sp anion--
no pi overlap, and an sp2
anion--
no pi overlap.
And Anurag, I'm going to do you
one more because you're
being so good to me here.
So we're going to take it away
from this hydrogen, which is
not on the triple bond--
this one the hydrogen was on the
triple bond.
Now we're taking it away from a
carbon next
to the triple bond.
Or here we're taking it away
from a carbon that's on a
double bond.
But it's also next to a double
bond.
Now why do you say it's good?
STUDENT: Resonance.
PROFESSOR: Resonance-- now you
got it right.
Because when it's not one that's
on this, either a
double bond or a triple bond,
but it's on the carbon next to
it, now it can point this way,
and be like that, and overlap
and get the resonance
stabilization, so you were
right.
So this is a HOMO-pi* overlap
finally.
And there we see it.
Now there are fabulous tables of
people who have measured
these things.
So, for example, this is a
website from a course at
Harvard, Chem 206, which has six
pages--
this is the first of six pages--
so all different pKa's of many,
many different compounds
losing their protons.
There's another compilation at
another website here, which I
think is even bigger.
So these are interesting tables
to look at to see if
you can figure out-- look at
molecules that are very
similar to one another--
so solvation will be more or
less the same and you don't
have to worry about that--
and see what it is about the
change from one
molecule to the next.
How can you explain in terms
like we've been talking
about-- hybridization,
resonance, electronegativity.
That is, the HOMOs and LUMOs.
How can you explain these trends
seen
over similar compounds?
So here's the problem for
Wednesday.
List the factors that help
determine the pKa for an acid.
Then choose a set of several
related acids from one of
these pKa tables, or your text
will have some, too, I'm sure.
And explain what they teach
about the relative importance
of these factors--
which is more important,
resonance or hybridization, as
we were talking about here.
So just practice yourself by
choosing a set of three or
four, or whatever number seems
to be there, of related
compounds where you see
structural changes, and see if
you can rationalize why they
have the pKa's they have. Then
once you've done that in the
privacy of your own room,
explain your conclusions to at
least one other class member
and decide together how
unambiguous your lesson is.
Did you think it through, or was
there something you forgot
or did you get something
backwards?
So that's your assignment for
Wednesday, and feel free to
consult the problems in
textbook-- they'll have
problems about pKa's, and the
references at the end of the
tables if you want to.
There's a hint that that would
make a good exam question for
you to explain something like
that.
Now, nucleophilic substitution
and beta-elimination.
So we've been talking about this
Brønsted acidity in order
to understand reactivity and
more
typical organic reactions.
So let's see if we could use
these ideas in understanding
nucleophilic substitution and
beta-elimination.
In the Jones textbook that's
chapter seven, but there will
be corresponding chapters in all
of the books that you
have. We also started talking
about this in lecture 16, as
you'll remember, where we talked
about acid base
reactions, and about SN2
substitution, and that they
really were the same reaction in
terms of the orbitals that
were involved.
In fact, the beta-elimination or
E2 elimination, remember we
talked about at the same time in
lecture 16 where the base
takes off this proton, you
generate the double bond and
lose the leaving group there.
Now these reactions weren't
discovered by people who
understood mechanisms and
applied them to see what they
could make in the laboratory.
They were discovered by people
fiddling around with things
and seeing what would happen.
And it's only 100 years or 150
later that people began to
really understand what was going
on.
So, for example, Alexander
William Williamson in Britain
in 1852 discovered that treating
this alkoxide with
ethyl bromide could do a double
displacement reaction
where you exchange partners and
the ethyl goes on the
oxygen and the sodium goes with
the bromide.
Finkelstein, who was a chemist
in the Netherlands in 1910,
found that sodium iodide
reacting with R-Cl could give
R-I, so you could exchange
iodine in place of chlorine
and get sodium chloride.
Now all these things have their
own little bit of lore
about them.
The reason that reaction works
so well is that sodium iodide
is soluble in acetone, the
solvent that's used.
But sodium chloride is not
soluble in acetone.
So when you mix the two, you
could imagine either of them
replacing the other one.
But the equilibrium is driven
toward the products by the
fact that sodium chloride
precipitates.
So all of these reactions have
their own twists about them
that make them interesting and
variable.
But there's generality, too.
For example, he could also do
this trick with an alkyl
bromide instead of alkyl iodide.
So if you could only do
something in one particular
case, no one cares very much
about it.
But if it's general, then people
can apply it to their
own problems and it becomes much
more interesting.
So generalization is the name of
the game here.
And both of those reactions, the
Williamson ether
synthesis, and the two flavors
of the Finkelstein reaction,
both of them involve exchanging
ions.
You start with one pair of ions
and you end with a
different pair of ions-- it's
one of these double
decomposition reactions.
Then in Russia, Menshutkin in
1890 discovered that you could
react triethylamine with an
alkyl iodide and
generate the salt--
tetravalent ammonium salt as an
iodide.
Notice that this seems to be
different from the first one,
because the first one just
exchanged ions; this one
actually creates ions where
there weren't ions in the
first place.
Or Hans Meerwein working right
after the Second World War in
Germany discovered that you
could use this thing called
Meerwein's reagent, which is a
special kind of oxygen--
oxygen plus because it has three
things attached to it.
Trimethyloxonium.
Fluoroborate is the anion that
he used.
This could react with RO- to
give R-O methyl--
that is, it's a methylating
agent, it
puts methyl onto oxygen.
But notice in this one you
actually destroy ions.
You start with four ions and you
end with two ions.
So at the top we have exchange
of ions, then we have creating
ions, now we have destroying
ions.
And then there's solvolysis,
where the reagent actually is
the solvent--
ethyl can react with the carbon
displacing bromide as HBr.
So that solvolysis means
breaking apart, that's the
"lysis" by the solvent.
So all these seem to be--
if you had a list of reactions
you'd have to memorize, we
have all these different
reactions--
the Williamson ether synthesis,
the Finkelstein
reaction, the Menshutkin
reaction, the Meerwein
reagent, solvolysis reactions
and so on.
But the great thing is that
they're all the same.
Once you understand the
mechanism, they're all
nucleophilic substitution, which
is the subject of this
part of the course, because all
of them have some
unusually high HOMO which reacts
with an unusually low
LUMO, which is the sigma*
orbital.
So it breaks the sigma* as the
new bond is
formed with the HOMO.
So if we're talking about the
generality of nucleophilic
substitution, we should
generalize over variety and
all the different components of
the reaction.
Just to give you an example of
how many different kinds of
nucleophilic substitutions there
are, consider adenine,
which has lots of different
unshared
pairs on the nitrogen.
And ribose, a sugar.
Now here you have a HOMO on the
nitrogen and a sigma*
LUMO of the carbon-oxygen.
And you can substitute the
nitrogen for the oxygen.
Actually, as we'll see shortly,
it's not quite the
same where you push the O-H out.
But anyhow that's a substitution
at carbon, which
loses water then, and makes that
N-H [correction: N-C] bond.
And that stuff is called
adenosine.
So the adenine, plus the "-ose"
comes from ribose, so
that's adenosine.
So we have adenosine.
And here's methionine, an amino
acid.
And it has a HOMO, which is an
unshared pair
on the sulfur there.
And it has an O-H that could be
a leaving group.
So you can substitute SR2 for
O-H at carbon and do another
nucleophilic substitution, and
you get this thing that's
called S-adenosylmethionine.
It's methionine that has this
adenosyl on it.
And that is this stuff you may
have heard of, SAMe,
S-adenosylmethionine--
you can buy it in vitamin
stores.
But it's very popular with
nature as well.
So if you have an amino acid or
something that has a
nitrogen with an unshared pair,
like the nitrogen in
arginine, then you can do a
nucleophilic substitution
reaction where you substitute
NHR2 for SR2.
So it attacks that carbon, the
leaving group leaves, so
here's the third nucleophilic
substitution reaction.
And it ends up with a methylated
amino acid.
Or that arginine could've been
part of a protein and you'd
have a methylated protein.
Then you could have another one,
where a base comes along
and takes the proton away.
But that's nothing but a
substitution at hydrogen, and
leave the electron pair on
nitrogen.
And this is biological
methylation, which I know
practically nothing about,
except for the fact that our
daughter, who was a student in
this course 20 years ago, is
now a professor of biology at
Bowdoin College.
She works on biological
methylation, on protein
modification by
methyltransferases.
I talked to her on the phone the
night before last
to check this out.
She says yes, indeed, this is
the compound that's used in
practically all biological
methylation
reactions of proteins.
So these nucleophilic
substitutions have broad
generality and are very
important.
And what we're going to be
studying then is how the
different components influence
the rate of these reactions.
So we have the nucleophile, the
high HOMO that's coming,
we could vary that.
We have the substrate, what
various R groups we could
have. Included in the substrate
is, of course,
whatever's going to be leaving--
the leaving group,
we could vary that and see how
it affects the reaction.
It takes place in some solvent,
that's going to make
a difference.
And, of course, there's some
product being formed.
So all of these things can vary.
And now, although we looked
schematically early on in the
middle of the semester--
last semester we looked at this
idea of the HOMO
attacking the sigma* and the
leaving group leave. Now
we're going to look at the
details of how, as you vary
these things, the reaction
becomes more or less easy or
takes some completely different
course.
So that's going to be the
project we begin next lecture.